if you're a parent you've heard about
the sexting epidemic and the latest from
the Journal of American Medical
Association is not welcome news a
surprising new study about teens and
sexting sexting it suggests it's on the
rise more common than you think could be
causing legal trouble for teens a new
study finds 27 percent of kids under 18
receive sext messages including nude
photos nearly 15 percent of teens send
them oh my god it's a heartbreaker and
now some experts say sexting should be
included in sex ed classes because it's
the new normal
let's ask behavioural and psychology
expert dr. Gina luden and
psychotherapist dr. Karen Ruskin all
right let's start with dr. Ruskin when I
read the experts say I usually ignore
them because of the same people who told
me to do dumb stuff when I built a house
and they were all wrong but now when
this is about kids now sexting can be
normal and healthy and we should teach
it in sex ed your reaction here's the
thing it is a very normal part of
development for teens especially older
teens to explore sexually sexting
meaning utilizing your phone to express
your thoughts and feelings is part of
the digital age and that is exactly why
having sex education would be helpful
because then you can talk about how to
do it
in a digital age that is being mindful
of not having sexed extortion not having
non digital censorship meaning or
meaning doing it in a safe way I know it
sounds ridiculous I know it sounds
ridiculous but the fact is there is
safer sexting that's consensual and then
there is not okay
fixing this consensual because sexting
means never having to say you're sorry
what happens at the big breakup oh sorry
Johnny this is what she sent me and then
he's that he screenshots it and then
you're off to the races
this is a nightmare that's why this is a
disaster for especially young women and
in there and I want to
or education on education not pick
education words you're in my classroom
here's my education don't sext okay
because if you sext you're giving your
car away dr. Lewton gone I know they're
doing a lot of dumb things their kids
you point to something that has been
proven through science in fact good
mocker Institute which is an arm of
Planned Parenthood not exactly a
conservative Mecca right they even said
that the more you teach sex ed the more
children have sex the more there is
unwanted pregnancy and the more abortion
ends up as a result and STDs by the way
but even even more recently you have
science direct pointing to the fact new
research that says that women are mostly
harmed through sexting and and so we
don't need it this is the role of
parents Laura no wonder kids are screwed
up today right when parents refuse to do
their job they turn it over to Big
Brother and now we're turning it over to
Big Daddy government schools bad idea I
want to play for you it will never work
I want to play for both of you a
heart-wrenching piece of videotape let's
watch bethenny Burt Lowe was in high
school when she sent a revealing shot of
herself to a boy she was dating but it
ended up in the wrong hands I just
wanted to be alone I felt horrible for
three years she says she received
threatening messages from an anonymous
number demanding she send more explicit
photos I got a text that said I have
some photos of you if you don't do what
I say you're going to regret it
the person on the other end of those
threats a former classmate found guilty
of exploiting her he remains behind bars
dr. Ruskin these are kids with moans
right this is exactly why this is
exactly why we need education to talk
about not sending pictures sexting need
not be sending pictures it could be
expressing yourself with words extortion
is you don't think the words convenience
against you how about this how about
going yes
you look at each other and talk to each
other and that's it and in that job and
this is the reality so that's why we
have to educate them yeah well I agree
we get rid of the finances
yeah well I'm just Boyd made my daughter
says when am I getting a phone I say how
does it ever sound um oh well yeah and
also I mean these statistics are bad and
they are they are shocking but I think
you're right I know if you have some
point education is important but what we
teach our daughters and our sons don't
give your power away you give your power
away you will never ever be able to get
some of that power back but it was a
great conversation we guys have to have
you on radio fantastic and you can be
empowering sexting can be empowering Oh
put that on a t-shirt dr. Ruskin